I know that there have been some talks
of season three already Brian Yorkie
said something about it where do you see
the show going I know I'm like I don't
know if that's a question I get like
yeah okay to be honest because there's
so many places for it to go I feel and I
think Brian is like it's mustard in his
brain so I definitely feel like we can
always explore more yeah but I don't
know it's it's it's quite that's it
that's a tricky one
do you think that there's a place for
Catherine Langford in season three
because so much of this season was about
clay letting Hannah go I mean I
personally as like someone who thinks
creatively I wouldn't think I feel it
would be forced okay but I mean it's
Catherine you know is so amazing but if
we want to do you know storytelling I
mean I don't know you know it's like I
don't know where would where wouldn't
feel force sure you know and she's gonna
be fine yeah she's so talented
she's amazing amazing I mean we couldn't
have been more more lucky to have found
her yeah
you